even after working for 18 years I
believe you are never too old to learn
new skills and acquire knowledge to
excel further and keep up the growth
that's why I decided to upskill myself
to own my skills to improve my
performance in my current organization
the course not only helped me to acquire
skills and get certified but also gave
me a decent salary hi hey I am ADI Cana
I live in Pune with my family I'm
currently working as a quality manager
at the S system Global Services I
recently got certified in the
postgraduate program in Lan Sigma in
collaboration with um must armrest from
Simply learn I a curious learner and
continuous Improvement is my Moto this
isn't the first time I choose simply
learn to upscale myself I even took the
project management course earlier which
motivated me to go for another one I am
working in the quality management domain
for 18 years now when I was assigned
position of quality manager I decided to
take up the course in Lin Sigma I wanted
to make sure that I'm fully updated with
all the recent case studies to master
myself in the field of quality
management the course boosted my
knowledge of case studies from Howard
business publishing and Capstone project
from KPM in India that provide real
world lead and Six Sigma exposure one of
the best attraction of Simply land
course is a well structured course
content that consists of all the
industry relevant modules and projects
the concepts were easier to learn thanks
to the pedagogy of the faculty
everything they taught was practical and
experience driven even the support team
made the learning smoother because of
their instant response and quick problem
solving the certification has already
made me stand out from the crowd and has
brought me closer to my goal of
excelling in the field of quality
management in my leisure time I spent my
time cooking delicious food and trying
my hands at new recipes I also love
photography and enjoy clicking pictures
with my DSL learning keeps me thriving
for Perfection it keeps me growing
professionally because growth is the
only constant that leads to
success